[Music]
Jack Ma is Asia's richest man and most
recognizable business tycoon he's the
chairman of Alibaba Chinese e-commerce
giant and one of the 10 largest
companies in the world yet he still
wants more we know where we're going
wanna be the fifth largest country big
words from the man's uncle Asia's Jeff
Bezos he's confident he's charismatic
and he's definitely not the average CEO
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is how a poor schoolteacher went
from the classroom to being one of the
most influential multi-billionaires in
the world
[Music]
Marv was born in China's southeastern
city haengju in 1964
his parents were traditional musicians
storytellers as a teenager he started to
learn English from foreign tourists
after China opened up in the late 1970s
and then for nine years Jack Ma hung
around outside the hotel Hotel which is
now called the shangri-la he would get
up at 5:00 a.m. to talk to travelers
that's Bloomberg technology reporter
Julie Chen and I cover China internet
for Bloomberg ma failed China's national
university entrance exam twice before
being admitted to the local Teachers
College he graduated in 1988 he applied
for 30 jobs and got rejected including
from the fast-food giant KFC KFC came to
check up I see 24 people went for the
job 23 people accepted I was not a guy
then Marv got a job at a local
university until English there for about
five years
earning just fifteen dollars a month on
the side he started a translation
company with several friends during a
company trip to the u.s. in 1995 ma had
his first encounter with the Internet at
a friend's place in Seattle I searched
the first award of beer I don't know if
it is easy to spell a baby and I see
beers from Germany beers from USA so he
searched for the word China instead and
still couldn't find anything and that
got him thinking he wanted to build
something that would put China on the
world's map he started China pages a
yellow pages like website but it didn't
take off then ma joined a government
agency in Beijing helped set up a
website by 1999 the internet stopped
boom had gripped Wall Street and back in
his hands yo apartment Marv decided to
try again with his wife and a group of
friends Marv raised $80,000 and set up
Alibaba
a site that allow businesses to sell
stuff to each other by 2000 Alibaba had
raised twenty five million dollars from
investors including Goldman Sachs and
Softbank
if you have no business plan and zero
revenue but his eyes was in 2003
Alibaba started Taobao a platform for
individual sellers to trade with each
other and publicly declared war against
eBay who had started to make a foray
into China
Chacma has this famous saying that
Alibaba is a crocodile in the Yangtze
River whereas eBay is a shark in the
ocean and if they fight eBay in the
ocean then they'll lose but if they
fight them in the Yangtze River then
they have a home base advantage
[Music]
in 2007 just one year after it force
eBay out of China
Alibaba debuted its business facing
division on the Hong Kong stock exchange
but it delisted five years later as its
performance sagged but in 2014
Alibaba raised 25 billion dollars in the
world's biggest IPO in New York
everybody should have a dream what if
that dream comes true after achieving
dominance in the business of e-commerce
in China Alibaba has been building an
Internet empire worth four hundred and
seventy two billion dollars with
businesses in cloud computing online
video streaming movie production
healthcare sports retail and even news
media although buying in to South China
Morning Post really raised eyebrows this
is the largest English newspaper in Hong
Kong and it shows that jack Moz
ambitions were limited to e-commerce he
wanted to influence not just Chinese
users but also overseas users as well
the u.s. is criticized Alibaba for
allowing companies to sell counterfeit
and poorly made goods but in China it
enjoys the favor of Chinese government
it's part of Mars company philosophy
they love with the government but don't
marry that we're done jack was an
extremely fortunate man for jumping on
the internet sector so early note that
this is a person who has no coding
skills at all he's a natural showman and
a gifted public speaker and really able
to convince others to believe in his
vision mass vision of growing Alibaba to
be the world's fifth largest economy
faces strong competition at home and
abroad it will require more than just
naked ambition in charisma but Maher is
great at getting himself in the right
place at the right time so far it's
well
you